love them in Boardwalk Empire as
narcisse The Hunger Games the James Bond
films Olli which I definitely want to
speak to this man about he's in West
world Sundays at 9:00 Eastern Time on
HBO Jeffrey Wright good to see you good
Caesar man oh man
we'll talk about Westworld in a second
but I want to talk DC sports with you is
that yeah is that where you are that's
where you've that's where you're from or
weird okay
yeah so you took in your first sporting
events in RF the old RFK I was born and
raised in RFK Stadium yeah my my mom had
season tickets to the Redskins from 1971
I think the first time I went to the
stadium was a senator's game 1968 if I'm
not mistaken and you know I was just I
was a huge I was a crazy sports for
anything with a ball attracted me you
know from a very early age I remember
going in the stadium with my godfather
and
I remember coming home and tell my mom
Wow Frank Howard slid into second and he
went under the he went under the dirt
and came back you know I was just so
mesmerized by what I was seeing the dust
flying and yeah it's still one of the
greatest thrills for me it's going in
new stadium walking up the stairs and
seeing the green of the field it's just
every any where they just get you know I
just tingle when I see that what RFK was
was a magical place well friend of mine
once took me to a Cowboys Redskins game
at RFK and in his family seats cuz ever
though nobody was buying single game
tickets yeah okay right everybody's
seats were family seats or they passed
down no question in the will they were
they were two rows from the edge of the
upper deck mm-hm there were just two
decks so we were in the second deck it's
two rows and we were hanging or it hung
over the end zone do you see anything in
the back of the end zone we had to stand
up and lean over yeah and I remember
when the Redskins took the lead the
place shook yeah literally it bounced
bounced yeah well it was such an
intimate space as you described there
were only two levels only 54,000 people
tight packed shaking and
had such a wonderful feel about it
because it was in Southeast DC where I
grew up which was kind of a place that
most folks only went to for a Redskins
game yeah but you had everyone in the DC
community gathering on Sundays to watch
that team play and it was just a special
it was just a special environment you
had a little jazz band playing in the
corner had a head of like had a very
subtle you know class to it and I've
been to the new stadium once mm-hmm
won't go back once because it's cold
it's out in the suburbs
Dease at RFK two levels divided by one
one ring and that's where the players
were listed that you know ring of fame
sure hell you had Larry Brown jergensen
all those guys listed there go to the
new stadium I think it has three tiers
and in between those rings you're the
first ring is FedEx and advertising and
all of this stuff the top ring is where
the players are listed so for me it
speaks to a hierarchy what the game what
the experience is about it's not about
those guys on the field it's about the
commercial aspects of it and it's just
it's just the feel of it is just off to
me it's cold
cops are staring at you you know
laughter the one game I win as opposed
to at RFK Stadium the cops were watching
the game I guess it was different times
back then no doubt that yeah totally but
so who was your guy growing up who's my
guy here my guy was Larry Brown Larry
Brown you know he was just this
thrashing daring you know just beautiful
play was just a beautiful athlete and he
just and he just gave it everything he
had every time he touched that ball at
me tummy touch the field so are you
through with the Redskins or you you
know because I know you don't live in
the DC area I don't I live in Brooklyn
now you know their jet giant of you know
I can't do that
I can't do that can't do that you know I
mean it's I cry when the Redskins lost
but they're it's a tough you know it's a
tough organization to get behind now
it's been 20 years of incompetence 20
years of failure and we as fans invest
our money my mom still got season
tickets we invest are our emotions and
in return as far as the team as the
organization goes we've got 20 years of
disappointment and that's a team that
was that was a story to organization you
know had had you know great success you
know three Super Bowls Doug Williams
leading the you know first black
quarterback to win a Super Bowl and it's
just been a diminishment of that I feel
in some ways my childhood has been has
been stolen from me because you just
look at it's just confusion one failure
one after another the rg3 thing that you
know the way that that that played out
he I know actually I did go back went to
another game with Archie three was play
the game he got knocked out
that's the yes the Falcons yeah which
one I was about to say which you could
you could name about five games that he
got knocked well yeah well that one was
uh that one was rough but he brought he
brought that energy back to DC and you
know he was running to the ground
whether he had something to do with that
whether he couldn't be managed properly
I think it's the responsibility of the
coach its responsibility the
organization to manage that situation if
I had been coach at that time the first
time he got knocked out of a game every
time he touched the ball and practiced
that following week he would have slid I
don't care if he was handing the ball
off and just sitting in the backfield he
would have slid well every time you got
that ball when it all comes down to it I
think when we look back on the RG three
years yes he's he's got some
fingerprints on it to know there's no
question about it but my point is
coaching is about leadership and you've
got a player who thinks he can do
anything you want
that player to think he can do anything
but at the same time you have to have
the strength of leadership to manage
that talent and that's that's that's the
way it goes I think Vince Lombardi would
have uh would have set him straight
would have put him in the right position
to protect himself and and lead the team
on in in a way that you know that didn't
end in his you know he's crumbling at
the end of the into the season let's
take a 60-second break back with Jeffrey
Wright we'll talk some Westworld I want
to talk about your role in the film Olli
I loved you in Boardwalk Empire I want
to know so much about your career and of
course West world on HBO red-hot show
Wednesday's a Sunday night pardon me at
9:00 Eastern Time we're back on this
Wednesday show with Jeffery Reich Josh
Rosen also still to come a Jeffrey
Wright of Westworld is here ask the poll
question based on some of the NBA action
last night Chris Brock yeah who do you
guys most want to see throw down go toe
to toe
draymond Green versus Charles Barkley
Barkley said he wanted to know what
someone knocked draymond greens lights
out yes okay that happen Perkins versed
Drake Drake and Kendrick Perkins got
involved former player now current
Cleveland assistant right I guess would
you say okay and Ken Giles versus own
face yeah the reliever who gave up the
home run last night and punched himself
in the face now that's tremendous would
you vote for what would you want to see
faceoff Jeffery right
yeah the punching oneself in the face
thing probably probably gonna end in a
draw yeah no that's not and well he
performs his own stunts Kent Drive
apparently yeah yeah yeah there it is
I'm sure you didn't see it he punched
himself in the face at least he didn't
hit himself in the head with the bat
that's Lisa tp'ed threw the bat right
down into the dugout but yeah that's a
bit Fremont versus Charles is that Lee
probably program dream on versa
yeah 46% right now okay dream on okay
barking yeah Barclays Barclays getting
up there I don't know I think maybe
that's why people want to see it maybe
drink Drake do you think Drake has would
actually throw drop gloves me hendrik
Perkins Jake's pretty jacked I don't I
don't think anyone wants to mess with
Kendrick Perkins oh yeah yeah no not so
much you know this is not an act
no yeah let's let's uh let's talk a
little bit about your your career what
was your the first thing that you did
how did you break in to the business the
first thing that I did was children's
theater in DC when I got out of college
doing folk history or history through
folktales for kids in DC metropolitan
area but so but in you know in some ways
that was my big break you know people
ask me that you know was your big break
big breaks the first time you get
onstage and and nobody you know hits you
in the head with a baseball you know
they say oh that's pretty good and one
thing leads to another so I left DC I
went to New York went to NYU quit after
a couple of months that's grad school
and then I came back and started doing
theater did theater for about seven
years until I wound up in Angels America
on Broadway and that was that was the
that was when I finally said to myself
you know after seven years of doing this
you know you're an actor first big film
role I guess was Basquiat 1996 something
like that but going back you know I did
have a performance at RFK 1972 October
22nd if I'm not mistaken
Redskins Cowboys I was the official
mascot for the game ran out onto the
field you know you know six seven years
old and I ran out and you know Mike
[ __ ] uniform and sat at the end of
the end zone and watch the game with
Landry on the side Landry Allen on the
other side yeah that was it was because
there was a department store the heck
company put your name in the box
you know those we might yeah I'll put
mine outside of it and put your name in
the box and two weeks later I get a call
saying they'd pick my heap
Dabangg and you know I was like I was
over the moon that was one of my from
yeah my first big performance and then
22 years later you got a Tony yeah it
works that's we can draw a line from
from Landry to Tony that's right there
al endorse Alan Alan okay come on come
on
George Allen by the way the the most
superstitious coach that Steve Sabol
told me ever came across go down George
Allen yeah where they miked him up for
NFL Films after years of him refusing to
do it and it might might have can you
look up if that was the game they mocked
him up against the Cowboys Cowboys were
killing him by 10 nothing at halftime
what was the date again October 2nd 1962
Redskins 124 - no 41 all I know is that
it was a Cowboys Redskins game and then
Allen was accused of or was reported
that he ran back into the dugout or area
because that was where an RFK going to
the Douga to go to the lockers right
that he got sick and he had to run out
but instead he ran he wasn't sick he ran
out to rip all the microphones off him
because they were swearing on him no he
thought it was it was superstitious he
thought it was bad luck because it was
something outside of what he normally
would do coaching again it was draining
his his life yes maybe that was Redskins
124 20 Cowboys red 13 seven at the half
so it wasn't that game but actually try
to connect the dots it was 13 nothing at
one point so Ollie did you ever meet
Howard Bingham we played absolutely what
was that like was fantastic the actual
photographer I guess the best friend of
ollie for Howard and I spent a lot of
time together because obviously I wanted
to understand you know him and I wanted
to find him sounds like that was him
yeah so it's been a lot of time with him
Howard is like the black Zelig he was
everywhere he knew everyone
he was even on the airplane he even
testified during the OJ trial because he
was only airplane that oj oj left town
right yeah he was in the Bronco but he
was on there so Howard was a just an
incredible guy and of course the reason
I took the
was because Holly's story and I wanted
to have a chance to meet Ali and hang
out with him and we were also shooting
in Africa we shot in Mozambique and I
wanted to do that and achieve all of
that and Howard introduced me to to Ali
and I spent a lot of time with him and
that was just like a you know how was a
little boy all over again I'll he was
manhood to me as a kid just to row up
beyond measure and I got to do a number
of things with him I got to do some
mundane things with him we were down to
Miami Howard said yeah Jeff Jeff you
want to go pick up Ali from the airport
I'm like yeah hang out here hotel room
yeah so we go down to the airport and we
pick up Ali and I'll never forget it
standing there and Ali's waiting by the
conveyor belt you know for his back and
he's just standing there waiting for his
bag and I'm fine I'm looking at this oh
man this is the most incredible thing
just seeing Ali just doing the ordinary
things man
yeah just have that to have that
intimacy intimacy with him was was
incredible the first time I met him
though we had dinner together lower
Manhattan after dinner we drove up 8th
Avenue he was dropping the ball New
Year's I guess this was 2000 2000 to
2001 perhaps
well Ali came out in 2001 so maybe it
was 2000 it was yeah yes yes yes 2000
2001 so so we drive up 8th Avenue and
I'm sitting behind him my wife at the
time was next to me
Ali's wife was was in the back he was in
front there was a Russian cabdriver and
Ali's you know you know had these
questions about his you know his mental
capacity and all he's going was strong
leader we like Osteria strong was good
leader but not crude like Chris you know
he was having this conversation or
arrest Russian heads of state we're
going to 8th Avenue
and we past Madison Square Garden and I
say to my wife at night and I'm going
holy and I said I said uh Holly Madison
Square Garden is in yeah did some work
in there and it was just like the most
incredible that is most right I will
ever have in my life well you've had an
incredible ride figuratively and
literally in your career
before we we go west world we had
Jonathan Tucker here earlier this week
he said his scripts are redacted to make
sure that there are no spoilers even in
the minds of the actors and actresses
are your scripts redacted but no however
however Westworld hierarchy well view
well yeah I guess so however in the
first maybe four or five weeks of
filming season two I shot because of
logistical reasons I shot scenes from
seven or eight episodes six or seven of
those I had not read fully so they were
kind of redacted in that way and then I
got my script I got my scenes okay
listen we're doing this and I'd ask a
thousand questions to figure out the
context do it and then I might you know
hop in my car and drive up the five in
my Bernard costume and go to the next
unit cuz we got a couple units going on
at the same time I'd get another script
another scene from another script that I
hadn't fully read it was just it's
pretty wild you know it's a it's uh it's
uh it's a it's a it's a game of
benevolent chaos that we that we play
with that thing so are you aware that
your character was a host a what he is I
didn't even see I you know I'd heard a
rumor but I haven't gotten to that
episode I'm talking down sit yeah I did
I was aware after the pilot I didn't
know during the pilot I just thought he
was kind of ordinary everyman Bernard
you know going about his thing doing you
know spinning his hamster wheel and you
know and working away there and then I
came back when we when we got picked up
and we started to shoot the second
episode Lisa joy who's the co-writer
co-lead writer of the show and the wife
of Jonah Nolan sat me down and and told
me that Bernard is not the man that he
thinks he is you know and yeah it just
blew my mind but at the same time it was
really exciting because it gave us a lot
more layers to explore and you know and
some secrets to keep season one I'm
giving anything away from see now I'm
being silly
no I'm talking to him over there cuz we
have a rule here Jeffery it's a 24-hour
and I'm just meant to be our rule right
there like you see if you snooze you
lose yeah if you haven't caught up if
you haven't caught up to you know
episode what was it seven now season one
then you know come on what are gonna do
Jeffrey I'm could talk to you all day
but I know you got a run I'm and Josh
Rosen and Johnny Damon are joining me in
our number three please come back boys
maybe we'll get into that hole since we
talked about in that whole name thing
with the Redskins you know I think you
mean the Washington Park yeah the
Washington football team yeah good to
see you here Jeffrey thank you for
having me you got a @j free write on
twitter follow him I do me and Jeffrey
Wright on Westwood every Sunday it was
world was you know what I did it again
you did that yes yeah and I was in
Westwood last night
gonna be here that's hot man West world
9:00 p.m. Eastern on HBO damn announcer
this whole conversation without Sikh
doing that West world 9 p.m. on HBO
great to see you two'll thank you you
got it the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience